this is a production of Cornell
University
but first of all
it's definitely a pleasure for me to be
here at Cornell in fact I had to play
Cornell has been on my bucket list
for a year because I used to read some
stuff from Dr David penmanthole and so
that's what really started me to be
connected but uh as Matthew said
I started farming in 1972. I was going
to go to the university and get a
master's degree in guidance counseling
instead I went and bought an 80 Acre
Farm and haven't looked back and haven't
regretted it and in 1975
is when I first did certified organic
and we were writing the rules uh
starting then
okay and then you know as it says here
uh I've never intended for it to be this
way I've only wanted to move for myself
what I hope others would do for
themselves
to generate pleasure happiness
and self-fulfillment
from being a farmer
and over the years
I started seeing things like this
that's Farmland in central Minnesota
in April very ready for Contracting
and that's not a desert that's timeline
those aren't sand dunes that's Shields
and we know what their land can do when
you have the precipitation
and the flashing of the Sun
you know protection of the elements and
uh soil and I'm and talking to some
people uh earlier this morning
I am excited about what I'm seeing as an
emphasis on soil Health water quality
and of course in my case organic farming
that it's still even picking up here on
campus are excited for me and it's all
it's really a pleasure to do that here
again just looking at some of the uh
issues
that's a drainage ditch and that's snow
that's drifted in and that's there's
snow under that black threat
and so we know that our issues are
something that need to be done
again we can see all we have really not
taken care of our soils and these are
the things
that I was picking up over the years
even as I was moving in or in advance
and so
that's what prompted me to really start
looking at the soil and what you see
there is the farm
uh where we live and about six or seven
years ago
I uh decided that I was going to really
reduce the tillage on that farm
and so when we harvest the corn and we
harvest the soybeans we leave the field
till the next spring
and that to me was a major change in our
operation because up to that point it
would always get out to get the crop
harvested in the fall and get the
tillage done and then leave it but what
we did in fact is change that we decided
we don't need to do that for those and
the way I learned that is that I've got
a son and daughter-in-law who live in
Cincinnati and so every Thanksgiving we
drive to Minnesota to Cincinnati we
drive through Iowa and Illinois and Ohio
and Indiana and we would see all these
fields that were harvested but nothing
else was done to them and I got the
thinking if these farmers
can do no fall tillage with their big uh
thousand bushel 1200 Bush for drain
parts and heavy equipment over those
fields and not be impacted by soil
compaction I should be able to do
something like that inorganics my
challenge would be when we eventually
but I should be able to do something
like that and so I got home and I I
started talking with two people and
that's what we did we eliminated the
fall chili
and uh it's made all the difference we
can see that but the reason I've got
these quotes up here is because I think
this is what's really driving us today
and we don't even realize it you know
the idea of local economy by uh Wendell
Berry
we will be wrong if we attempt to
correct what we perceive as
environmental problems without directing
the economic oversimplification that
caused it or and I'm talking about the
Midwest corn soy makes corn soybeans
foreign
simplification is now either a matter of
corporate Behavior
or behavior under the influence of
corporate behaviors
this is sufficiently cleared to many of
us but here's a piece where we come in
what is not sufficient to clear perhaps
any of us is the extent of our
complicity how we carry it on ourselves
by what we do day to day and so that's
as individuals and especially as
individual consumers
how do we promote what's going on that
that's our question to really face but
we have to face it and then we look at
that and how it's How it applies the
economy
we are drifting into amounts to a
reversion a throwback to the fuel is a
system from our European ancestors that
had escaped from there if we look out in
Midwest Minnesota
we've got Mega Dairy operations eight
nine thousand
cows under one road
we've got hog operations that are
industrialized thousands hadapons we've
got six or eight or ten Barnes for
polishing them and this is what we're
going to be talking about here except
for the core of managers the corporate
structure will be dwarfing to the human
spirit
if we're just looking at production in
an industrial manner in much of
Agriculture the man or woman on the land
will not be an imaginative innovator but
a faithful follower of written
instruction
because if if I'm trying to manage ten
thousand dairy cow
all I can do is follow the rules that
the boss said I can't be creative the
opportunity isn't there and so that's
where uh the be an organic farmer has
always been so fulfilling because I can
be creative I can be creative to the
degree that I choose and the other thing
is and the question is
why do we have why don't we have a lot
of sustainable agriculture Dr Richard
Levin was a good friend of mine a
retired AG Economist and he really
pointed it out to me here he says I
think we would be closer to answering
this question and could face the fact
that farmers no longer sit in the
driver's seat
if I call myself a farmer and I'd try to
operate 10 000 cows I'm not in charge
somebody else is in charge so we are
entirely too quick to say for example
that we had problems with Farm chemicals
because farmers use it you don't see it
because biochemical companies develop
manufacturing commercial
there's a reason why they're promoting
so clearly farmers are not the decision
makers in poultry production and much of
all production due to Contracting and we
see this in Gary as well we are no
longer in charge when you look at how
industrial agriculture moves my concern
is that we might be looking at that in
organic production as well into the
future but let's let's look at what I've
been able to achieve and what I see a
lot of my organic farmers being able to
achieve over the years and obviously
this is a cartoon but it's really really
says a lot of what what is going on out
here how we've let
uh uh corporations and a large industry
really take over our food system but for
me it all started back in the
1950s when I had a child growing up on
the farm there was a magazine laying on
the kitchen table that was called
organic gardening environment
and I would listen to my dad and my
uncle talk about organic gardening and
farming and not realizing that all that
conversation was being soared in the
back of my head here and so it started
coming out in 1961 as this picture shows
where I was a freshman in college but my
dad was already innovating new practices
on the farm back in the 40s 50s 60s the
more plow was the way to do the pillars
but a neighbor an implement dealer in
town came out one day and said I've got
this chisel file that uh you should try
and so that's a picture of the simple
plow that my dad started using actually
back in the 1940s and 50s but it created
in me an idea of being creative being
Innovative trying new things
and uh that really stuck with me I had
opportunity after opportunity to be
interviewed by people
um the video things about what was going
on on the farm in a a professor at the
University of Minnesota told me like if
you want to really learn what you're
doing
start preaching it or not preaching it
but start talking about it and start
trying to educate other people about it
and then you will begin to find out how
much you actually learned so what I'm
getting interviewed by people I better
know what I'm talking
and if I don't uh I'm gonna not look too
sharp
um the farm has always been uh
turn anything and I should back up a
little bit get a little background on
the farm we have about 400 acres and a
young family is now taking over the
operation and together with what he has
and what I had we have about 1200 Acres
about 900 Acres tillable
and about uh 300 uh in uh 200 and Grays
and plaster wet a lot of the short
prairies things of that sort but that's
the operation and uh
um in the 1980s we were going to have an
Organic certification
meeting on the farm
and an hour before that meeting started
we had all the third players on the farm
County weed inspectors drove up
and said you better do something about
those Canada thistle in that field
and so that was me you know it was a
wake-up call but it was also a teachable
moment I said if I'm going to be
successful in Organics I better learn
how to manage weeds not control them but
manage them manage them to a level that
I can do profitable at and that that's
what started me really thinking along
those lines
I tried to do organic from the very
first but it was and it's still
conditioned today to be just uh a work
in progress to failures and I've been
recognized at various things I did have
the privilege of serving in the endowed
chair and sustainable systems at the
University of Minnesota in 1997. again
an opportunity for our Farmers to be
directly engaged in the work that takes
place in the university and try to bring
some of that information some of that
research some of that work all to the
people and so that was a tremendous
opportunity for me so what are the
principles that I've learned over the
years as far as organic
I'm going to go through this directly
but these are basically what they are
commitment to organic must be
philosophical social and economic
in that order
it's got to happen up here before you're
going to be successful on the land and
that doesn't happen to a lot of people
and so that is so critical organic
production with a conventional attitude
will not work I can say any number of
Founders here I'm going to go in there
because I get eight nine ten dollar form
a year in and year out
foreign
acceptable
weed men will always be a big challenge
what is acceptable and it's not
acceptable based on what you need to say
it's acceptable about what's your bottom
line
and that will be probably one of the
biggest
adequate's uh fertility levels will be
challenging but doable we can't just go
to local fertilizer store and buy
hurdles we've got to figure out how to
maintain soil capability in different
ways rotations whatever we'll get into
that
you have to think and act positive I can
be uh about this time of year I'm not
sure I'm doing the right thing on the
farm I see all these things that didn't
work out and so we did crop harvested
and the snow start client and I sit
around the house and say yeah I think I
can make this work in the middle of
January yeah I'm ready to get out there
again I know I've got all these issues
solved and so we'll get out this
planning in the spring get the crops in
and then I start calling a rotors away
and I start seeing weeds and whether it
is raining right where I and whatever
and everything about again middle of
July or obviously why am I doing this
why don't I just follow the local
fertilizer store the chemical store go
up and spray that North 40. I could
sleep at night and it happens every
cycle to go over and over and over so
you've got to think positive and you
gotta act positive
um be oblivious to peer pressure and I
would say less time in the coffee shop
more time driving around those fields
with the four-wheeler and looking at
what's going on there
perseverance and patients are required
character attributes you you cannot give
up absolutely you've got to persevere I
can tell you over and over when I've had
issues with a field that I
mowed off a field I've worked under a
few because it got away from me it's the
tuition that's that's tuition we're
talking a little bit about that
diversity I should talk self-reliant and
creative mind
uh prerequisites
you really think these things through
and
how do I do that and I'll show you
something a little bit later but keep
that one in mind higher price is no
substitute for lower yields
if you can't get your farm to be
competitive with all of your neighbor's
yields you still have work to do
and it can be done
but you still have work to do and we've
proven that over the years that it can
be done
marketing always think twice about
marketing you might be able to Market
your crops at a good price but are you
keeping in mind how you're going to help
some of your fellow organic farmers
protect that price
by making sure that all of you can get
that good price instead of just looking
after yourself so that's what we really
mean by not going alone in marketing
and seek out reliable sources to educate
yourself when I started we were writing
the rules of organic in fact I helped
write some of the original rules and it
went into the organic standards we were
writing those in the 1980s and combining
it we were talking to people like mobile
but we were writing the rules but today
you can go on the internet for hours and
hours and hours and find all the
information you want on organic for sure
don't become an evangelist build it and
the people will come will come there's
no question about it
in the early years I was an adult car
management and the adult farm management
instructor would come up uh once a month
and we have a farm visit
when Connor wondering what you're doing
out here now today
and every once in a while I have some of
our friends say yeah we're sitting in a
coffee shop the other day and the
question came up sold what's the crazy
Department he said Madison doing in the
farm now look at those weed look at this
look at that
um I don't know if you know or knew uh
the poet Robert Glide
but anyway Robert Blythe World we're not
poet was one of my greatest supporters
he loved what I was doing out there I
had two or three people in town that
totally supported me but the point is I
wasn't listening to anything I was
focused on that farm Why didn't it work
this year or why did this work and that
that's where I had to be and network
going to Workshop reading YouTube it's
all out if you look for it you can find
it
expect failure
it's called tuition
and I won't want to even tell you how
much solution I paid over the years but
if you don't learn from it it's not
doing any good but expect it it's going
to be there and the big thing is
attitude
you gotta think positive you got to
think I can do this I'd rather be able
to ask people about it and so fear of
wheat when I when a person calls me and
asked about organic
how do I deal with weight
we psychology it's taking me four to ten
years and I still haven't figured it out
but we're learning from year to year we
figure out okay this didn't work how can
we do this I was telling somebody
earlier this morning
I've been working on tweaking a
cultivator a roll crop cultivator for 45
years and we're still tweaking it after
the cultivating season is overlooked the
young Farmers taking over we sit and say
okay next year we got to do this next
year I do this it's a constant work in
progress uh peer pressure decision
like I said stay away from the coffee
shop figure out what you got to do on
your client because you're writing your
paycheck nobody else keep that in mind
and finally make a profit no matter how
much it costs when I look at how people
throw money looking for the Magic Bullet
whether it's an organic or not
that's not the approach if everybody is
doing the same thing
only one person
okay so that's again you know depend on
yourself depend on your creative skills
to do it
um this is the soybean farmer from the
Madison area
and he had an article written and he
said like other American soybean Farmers
I know will ultimately win and he was
talking about
the resistance that we were gaining uh
some of the newest chemicals
so all I could respond was really
weeds there's the reason why we throw
around they're survivors they always
will be survivors we have to attitude we
got to think about it you know we made
uh 30 000 actually the cost of sixty
thousand you can't buy your production
you've got to figure out how to do it
you know
on an organic file
reading labels and following directions
is not an option
it's what you become creative with is
what you can do with what you've got to
work with for sure
you are in charge
absolutely you make the decision
you certainly can't help with it but you
make decisions
and I keep coming back to this you know
eyes belong to the anti-block provides
of season and West Jackson and other
people have said it there's much more to
be discovered
and to be invented I've got a
four-wheeler I think that's like no
that's not the next question I've got a
four-wheeler
that I need to put on uh four to five
hundred miles of Summer
going out and looking at the field and I
never get more than three miles from
home but I put that many miles on it
every summer going out there looking at
what's going on in that today and so it
seems like manure is a problem robots
get locations under the crapper fishing
Grant and green manures and it's always
alternative inputs not lower income
I bought you know finally a live
document or uh prior to getting a herd
going on the front I would buy uh 10 to
20 000 worth of livestock in there a
year for facilities as an alternative
because it's not lawyers Rotation by two
or three thousand dollars worth of
public under seating millennium
alternative input cultivating instead of
terrain all of those kinds of things
come into it
and no farmer likes to mess up but there
is part of me looking forward to my next
mistake so I can learn and get better
absolutely
I never had this happen to me but I
think you get the message
we do make mistakes and organic has to
be timely but this is what we're talking
about
I'll drive around all the time checking
things out what's going on seeing trying
to see what's going on in those fields
and see what you're seeing
don't just look at it see what you're
seeing and make decisions about it make
judgments about it and don't be afraid
to change and the other thing is you
know uh I should back that up a second
it's very psyched specific in management
specific where you farm out here in the
figure-related region it's totally
different from out there on the plans
where I always tell people it snows
sideways okay so we all got wind and we
get the Heat and it can get pretty dry
and it's all foreign
and I I come out to this part of the
country to prepare that I looked at the
Lakes and everything else the roads are
very straight but and what the heck
let's see it and uh so it is you manage
with what you've got where you live for
sure
and finally you know again if
everybody's doing the same thing there's
only one person thinking so uh we always
keep those things in mind
so the other two things the timeliness
and patience
and timeliness uh
20 years ago I had this uh people come
back to Madison and they were going to
start farming and doing uh
[Music]
Garden assignment and I said one of the
things that you're going to find
yourself doing
is watching the sky
because the weather and I'll show you
something shortly the weather is going
to be a great determinant
that's going to decide what to do when
you do it and so timeliness and patience
come into play do I go out there and
plant today do I go out there and order
a whole today do I cultivate tomorrow
when do I plant the corn exactly we'll
cover some of those things
so what are the challenges and we can
summarize that fertility
and weather
compaction and whatever
planting dates and whatever
seed bed prep
and weather
paperwork record keep it inspection and
certification markets and marketing
weather
rotations and weather equipment weather
read feedback and weather
mechanical weed management and weather
rotary hole High leader plane meter
cultivators weather
determines your success
and the more you can work with it the
more successful you will be
and one thing since I started farming in
1972 till today the weather forecasts
have improved significantly in fact I
can have this cell phone with me and
check the weather experience hour by
hour and no should I get on that
cultivator now or should I wait and you
start learning the history of the
weather but it will determine your
success there's no question about it
and I I picked this cartoon up uh and
it's essential Church it seems to do
some question asking who is in charge
and I think we do know who it is we will
always be the big thing I'm not going to
go through all these but if you look at
some of the statistics here those
numbers were unbelievable
weed management
is mechanical and biological
biological but I mean by rotation
especially and by using certain crop
Legend uh cover crop all those things
mechanical because the accelerator
rotary hole all those things but it is a
two-pronged approach for sure and so
here's generally the rotation that I
will use we'll have a small grain a lot
of times we used to undersee it with a
legend but now what we'll do is Harvest
a small grain and then do a light
Village and put in a cover crop turnips
radishes uh field seeds sunflowers a
couple of mixes and then with the with
the herb that we just introduces the
form of beef powder uh in lay it over
when that cover crop is standing like
this with Grace and and it provides the
source for the college for another month
or so but then we'll we'll uh we'll have
a small grain it could be a real it
could be alfalf after it there could be
just a cover crop corn soybeans and then
back to it we're gonna what we're trying
to do here is try to figure out how we
can innovate and introduce hernza into
this because
it turns a lot operate a lot the same
way as Alfalfa as a perennial so
locations are working progress and we
will take the function as well as Market
opportunities what is the market looking
going to be what do they want but also
Paul is my weed management happening
how's that facility happens with these
little patients and uh keeping those if
you may not be able to read that but
that is the inside lid of the grain
drill that my dad had back in the 1940s
and he would put on there the date when
he started planting each year he was
collecting data back then already on how
things would work well and in the 1980s
I bought a 300 soil thermometer and I
kept track of the soil temperatures our
our an hour and say it would accumulate
35 days until I could start seeing the
soil temperature Trends and then I
started also putting soil temperature
Trends with it's a weed sea germination
and crop germination out of Vape
correlate and it came to realize that
soil temperatures for every 18 degrees
of salt temperature rises the micro
population in the soil doubles
so the soil temperatures go up nitrogen
levels move down in the soil I'm
building my own source of nitrogen okay
and why is that important because with
that salt thermometer I was able to
track and this will get one month out of
the air I was able to track the soil
temperatures for one month and the red
line at the soil temperature and the
yellow line is the air temperature
well I found and I'll show you this uh
right here May 20th is when it's all
temperatures in Minnesota started
staying above 50 degrees 24 7. I looked
at one that's corn and when the soybean
best germinate when the salt factors say
about 50 degrees
when did some of the Reeds germinate
some are going to be germinated later
some of them are going to be germinating
uh uh before that with some of the
information I was picking up with that
soil the model so the conclusion was
that I always get this old snap right in
the second week in May in Minnesota we
all called the fishing opener and we've
had snow
uh on fishing opener so I knew that that
wasn't going to happen the thing I'm
finding out even as climate change is
seems to be affecting us those dates are
still holding quite true
so after the 15th or 16th of May when I
started looking at foreign
because that's when I know I can get the
seed in the ground it's going to get up
early and I can get ahead of it with
cultivating and weed management learning
all these learning tools putting that
stuff together being creative thinking
about what I've got to work with that
that's what makes it uh it's so
rewarding and at this time of year I'm
really excited that the things are fun
together like I told you from June or
July or August and not to shoot but
we keep trying in tears so and and then
learning from people and a name that
comes to mind is Matt Legion from Iowa
State who has done some terrific
research on
uh
some of this data and the bottom one
especially is something else
a single female field Cricket sheltered
by grassy strip who eat more than 240
weed seeds in the 24-hour period
if I'm looking at weed management why
not have the Crickets and some of those
people helping us
that they're again seeing what you're
seeing learning what you can do on your
farm
and uh oh yeah there's some special
great literature out there as well that
can really help you out
so is growing organic milk crop the
viable option you may not be able to see
some of these numbers but uh I was I I
was an adult Farm business management
from the first year that I found all the
way up until I quit farming and we would
crunch numbers
my bottom line is that some crops were
profitable some were not I always put
I'll stop in a rotation but if I were
going to go on this chart and tell you
that I made money after I'd probably say
no I was losing money but there were
non-cash benefits
I was building soil health and I was
doing a lot of good weed management
tools and those were actually becoming
my herbicide so that's what those are
what I call the non-tactions but those
are the things that I was starting to
learn right there and by doing that farm
business management I was able to uh
know what those numbers were so I'm
going to fast forward to 2011.
and
uh I would introduced to
parents of perennial weeks and Dr Don
Weisman University who I've worked with
to get it for some 30 years uh he said
you want to try some uh
no problem but uh this looked like an
opportunity because it's a perennial it
comes back each year and yet it's a prop
that will produce a grain we should be
able to harvest it but what is the
challenge and the challenge is that
growing harvesting and moving new brain
with food grade quality
into an economically viable Market long
term
reliable adequate amounts becomes a
challenge a new company or a company
wanted to put in a new product are they
going to be that quick to do it so it's
going to be a learning curve that's
going to go a long way so that's that's
what the challenge was this is what the
currency field will look like I should
back up that no that's good that's what
the currency field will look like in
early March or April and it it gets
great and it will look like that as well
in September and October after you've
harvested it so it comes back and
performance creates a beautiful color so
what are the agronomic challenges
you know should you grow organic or
non-organ and a rotation where it can
fit it into your rotation I'm not going
into details because I'll be around this
afternoon if there's one more detailed
questions but these are the things that
we're looking at where do I get C how do
I prepare the seed bed seating equipment
uh I could tell you that most of the
equipment in fact all the equipment that
we use on our regular cup works just
fine with with curves so it's it's
definitely not an issue but how do how
heavy duty what's the seating the
fertility date Hospitality how do you uh
put the facility on and when do you do
it weed management is there a challenge
with weed management because uh up to
two years ago there weren't even any
herbicides that could be used in a
conventional system and so we've manager
Harvest sign and Equipment both Harvest
storage and processing all these things
and this is what Carson will look like
both up when it's pollinating so you get
an idea of that picture and so what are
the financial risks robust price
Discovery uh uniform food grade
decreased yield over time grazing and
forage opportunities
all these things uh or certainly some of
the challenges that we looked at and uh
ability for me to go into detail because
I could spend uh two or three hours just
talking about that this is what the seed
had looked like when it's about ready to
harvest okay and so we've got the
seating rate we're looking at about 12
to 15 pounds of
of pure live feed per acre harvesting it
we found that the three different ways
to harvest it the stripper had worked
the best because when the grain is ripe
and the seed head is right the center
field grass seed and so you have to
figure out how you can keep from all
that grass grease up getting anything up
the stripper head just takes the strip
it takes the sea to head out leaves the
rest of the crop Sandy or we can put it
in a wind roll and then let it dry for a
few days and harvest it that way or you
can straight cut it straight cutting and
really is a challenge because you do get
a lot of green sand into the hopper and
makes it a less quality product but
that's what it will look like when it's
harvested and in the hopper you can see
turns it looked like a miniature wheat
seed and I say miniature because about
the third maybe a third the size of a
funnel of wheat but that's what it will
look like a lot of hulls on it yet but
it's there
and so uh the Big Challenge was how are
we going to Market it so we can grow it
anybody can grow it but who's going to
buy it so we put together a co-op in
Minnesota we've got about 35 Growers and
what we're trying to do is balancing the
development and the production and
utilization there's one thing you can
grow all this stuff it's no Market what
are you going to do with it and you
can't just leave it sit in a bit so uh
you know these are some of the things
that are being used to be what it's been
used for but this is the actual picture
of the currency field right before it's
getting right what I love about this
field is that's organic
and it looked like it's going to be a
really good weed management tool that's
the beauty of the field but we're
talking about the marketing we got to
meet the needs of farmer producer and
help them figure out where it's going to
be marketed and
It's A New Concept it's perennialized we
planted one year and we planted in uh
late August and then the next three
years it comes back and see what I've
been planted in harvested but there are
some challenges because we need a chance
to drop off and so how can we figure
that out lots of work being done on it
uh we figure there's about 15 to 18
years yet of work to get current uh to
be competitive with wheat yield wise
so that tells you where we're at in the
development Stadium but there's some
products out there now already and
people are using them
and uh we're still working on uh Market
development we've got a great working
relationship with the University of
Minnesota you know we got the girls pull
up it's a direct connection with nrcs
will work with them we're working with
USDA and we're working with the
University of Minnesota we we have a
crops out there and see us they're doing
the research in the labs in fact this
year we'll probably be planting about
five acres of a new variety
that hopefully will be the new release
in 2024 a variety will probably have
doubled the seed size and increased the
yield by 25 we're talking uh
five six hundred pounds of seed
production per acre
on currency and once you get it clean
and food grade ready you're probably
only looking at about 300 pounds of
usable products
so there's two two issues there if
you're only going to have 300 pounds of
green
are you going to make it competitive
with the rest of the crops so the co-op
is working on the markets and we've
figured out what that grain is worth
uh based on yield but based on what I
can get off of other crops and so work
pricing organic uh kernsa at five and a
half to six dollars a pound which is
going to grow so it's in that twelve to
fifteen hundred dollars and indica will
be competitive with Organic porn and
organic soybeans those are the kinds of
things that the co-op is working on so
yeah we do have this great collaborative
effort with the University of Minnesota
if I had more time I'd tell you a funny
story about Don but I don't have the
time but I would talk to other people
about the uh
Forever Green initiative these are all
of the crops that are either winter
annuals or perennials that are being
developed primarily at the University of
Minnesota because we're looking at
perennials and continuous living cover
on the land as a driver for future
research and crop development and these
are the things that they're working on
and currents that happen to be the
posted child at this point it's the one
that seems to be the farthest along as
being a really marketable crop and so uh
if you just go on Google Forever Green
initiative
all the information will be out there
for you
but marketing of course has been the
biggest challenge but here's the piece
that I really want to emphasize there
and that is this if there's no margin
there's no Mission so if I can't deduce
a crop and and generate a profit my
mission is better it's not going to
happen so in terms of marketing terms of
must be monetized at a level reflecting
these services and these Services must
remain in part of the terms of market
price Discovery so what we're really
emphasizing when we're marketing turns
out
at that per acre Revenue generation that
12 to 15 1600 we're not only getting
paid for the grant we want to get paid
for the ecosystem services that that
crop will provide soil Health water
quality and continued social viability
to get new and younger Farmers able to
come on the land and continue farming so
it's an ecosystem services that we
really want to drive when we're talking
about these forever green crops and in
particular right now the current itself
and there again that's what it will look
like in in the hopper you can see some
of the green stems some of the things
that are there
but that's what it is I've done this
thing quickly we're just about out of
time because if I were going to do the
organic thing I've got fair and 50
slides and I've done a lecture that's
been all day it's been four or five
hours so you can tell you it can tell
you how fast I've gone through it but I
tried to hit the high spots and if
there's time for breakfast I'm open but
whatever yeah
yeah thank you so much that was very
Illuminating I was really getting
excited when you talked about creativity
um but then I was sort of disappointed
that you're advocated against coffee
shops
because I think you are a Trailblazer
and you are a first doctor so the coffee
shop was probably a bad idea but now
in an Ideal World how do you see
peer-to-peer learning that catalyzes the
adoption of sustainable practices and
and what you're talking about because a
lot of people could learn from you maybe
in a coffee shop maybe somewhere else
but but how do you see that now that
that is a critical uh mass of people
that that can actually be learned from
how can we make this peer-to-peer
learning better uh excellent question
and I guess I've been I haven't noticed
it because uh I'll get two three four
calls a week
on questions about currents and organic
but for me it's been going on but you
make an excellent point what we've done
is have a field day each year and we've
got uh infrastructure out there that has
Field Days around the country that's
only one day
I think
I think universities like Cornell could
start developing some um how could he
say it
some
workshops some
some
uh series of meetings throughout the
year what we really want to do with
current in fact is over the winter
months
have a series of get-togethers in uh in
the city where people could come
together and just sit and talk about
these things
uh I think the other ideal place we were
at the Ithaca Bakery this morning I
think there should be a room in there
that would provide the opportunity
absolutely
um
we've got to make that happen because
that's what we you know we've got we got
the cell phone we got all these things
but there's nothing to substitute for
eye to eye sitting in the same room
talking so we've got to make that happen
your point well taken for sure
yes
the
separated
and I feel like you touched on that a
little bit here and I'm wondering what's
the current economic structure in the
midwest
two coming together again so bringing
together uh the livestock and the field
production
uh over the years
uh
I I don't think there's been enough
research to point that out
uh because to me a lot of the benefits
of livestock in the system are going to
be what we'd call non-cash benefits
and the data and the research has not
been able to put a value on those
non-cash benefits the same way as I was
emphasizing on the ecosystem services in
terms of in fact we've been talking
about that in our Co-op meetings and
with Barbara how do we put a value on
those uh ecosystem Services how much
value is there in keeping the the
nitrogen some seeping into the Wellhead
protection areas how much value is it
from keeping the soil in place instead
of where it was on on those pictures I
showed you that research is critical and
if there's one place that I would love
to see uh research in a an egg and
agricultural areas of any University
that's trying to define those values
because if we put a dollar value on that
it will change to see quicker absolutely
well
fairly addressing if you uh mentioned
social viability and you know it's one
thing I think
there's uh
uh there's aging out where you have this
brainy drain a lot of fun with people
how do you position your young people
sitting in rural communities who are
coming back to you know uh
number one policy
okay policy does not uh reward farmers
who want to get another farmer engaged
in their operation
policy says in order for me to be a
profitable I have to get bigger and
bigger and bigger that's the number one
the other thing is uh when I talk about
marketing and I said don't go It Alone
in marketing and work with others to
make sure you protect that market that
in fact was a purpose when the major
purposes for the co-op is to protect
that five and a half and six dollar per
pound
price of that currency I'm not going to
get that if I go to the market by myself
but if all 35 of us in that Co-op go and
get that six dollars what are we doing
we're generating income not only to make
the far profitable but to support the
infrastructure and the social structure
of that community so it is policy but
it's also a responsibility of The
Growers itself
over the years what I was able to do
because everything organic and I was
receiving pricing for organic that were
above the conventional prices so when
Luke Peterson came to me and we all the
time figured out how he could take over
the farm what I was able to do with Luke
is say yes
uh I think you can make I think you can
make a good living on this Farm because
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give you a reasonable rate on cash rent
but I'm also going to let you buy my
equipment over a period of time in other
words I'm going to finance you
and it was a tax benefit for me and a
way for him to get in but because of the
higher prices I'd gotten for organic
over the years I was in a situation
where I could do it uh the other thing
is so we wanted to do livestock he
wasn't in a position to buy a a by the
college I said Luke I'll buy the cows
because it's again a tax benefit for me
and it's a benefit for the fire and you
can keep the cash and I'd keep the cows
and over time uh I'm getting attacked I
think we're getting the power those type
of things so it's two things it's policy
and it's a farmer's planning to do uh
doing some planning to make sure that
they can put a young Farm on that farm
with some kind of reliable way of making
a profit if you're going to buy any kind
of equipment uh on a on the interest
that I have together now
you're going to have a cup you're going
to really have the equipment you need
you're going to be looking at at least a
million dollars worth of equivalent
a million dollars just for equipment
we're not even talking about uh seed
costs and input costs and all those
things so you've got me as older Farmers
have got to figure out how to be able to
set up and help the young ones if again
I come back to those two pieces and
that's what I mean when I emphasize that
social piece of ecosystem services that
to me is critical
absolutely critical but we haven't
talked about that nearly enough and
uh it won't get back to University of
Minnesota but I'm not I don't care
the University of Minnesota has failed
in rural sociology
and that the piece that I think is
always missing the rural sociality how
do you talk about the impacts of the
girl if you're not going to figure out
how to fix
are you even finding leaderships that
are out
well let me get on that call for this so
maybe one more question okay go ahead
very question okay
currents or creative Innovative cropping
systems is the challenge
um how are you are you seeing anything
promising in the pipeline for supporting
farmers who are taking alternative
options organic options
um
I probably got the best drop of chance
in the world
I mean yeah seriously because if I want
a new crop in my location
you will figure out how we get carpentry
things
he will sit down and help do it and so
uh it's not always easy but I do see
policy changes in the crop of spirit
world I see the government being much
more open to Innovative crop and trying
to provide some kind of safety net there
so it is moving in the in the right
direction from what I've seen and so I'm
optimistic about that a couple years ago
I wanted to drive cop
until the middle of July to get that
insurance for those heat but it we got
uh Luke is working on sunflower and and
we're getting that covered so if part
you know doing your own part of it but
pushing the system as well
great thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu